each year Microsoft Research hosts
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so I'd like to introduce Tiberio caetano
who works at national ICT in Australia
where I also work so he comes from
Brazil originally by a way of of Calgary
Edmonds up Oh admit this re edmonton
alberta yes so extremes of temperature
he's went through he did his PhD there
in graduated in 2004 before coming to
work in Australia I hired him into the
vision group there but he jumped ship
into the machine learning group at some
point so he has expertise in both the
vision and machine learning and I think
he's going to give a talk which bridges
the two areas today Thank free shirt for
the introduction so essentially I'll try
to divide this talk in two parts so the
first part will be a very generic talk
about the type of work we are doing in
computer vision and essentially using
machine learning methods to to solve
computer vision problems and the second
part all which is probably going to be a
little bit shorter it's basically going
to be a bit more specific about one
recent project okay so i would like to
thank my collaborators so Oh Jerry
fairies from IBM TJ Watson Research
Center are some of my PhD students here
Julie McCauley Jeff and she Coakley the
Cheng over there long beach n alex mall
here are collaborators involved in these
projects here that i will describe i
think i missed the picture of Dale
Sherman's with a nada collaborator in
this projects i'm going to present to
you ok so as i mentioned i will divide
that presentation in two parts so the
part 1 will will be essentially
preaching
structure prediction in computer vision
I'll quickly describe what this means
and give examples of of this the second
part then we'll be a little bit more
specific about recent work with just
submitted okay so let's focus on the
first part structure prediction computer
vision so this part I'll first talk
about what I call easy vision problems
and so here's an easy vision problem I
want to find a class of this object okay
say okay this is a bike I'm calling this
a easy vision problem so imagine what I
call a difficult vision problem so
here's yet another easy vision problem
what's the class of these objects so I
find it easy so that's that's a car a
very typical car and yet another is a
vision problem what's the class of these
object data so that's a ship also an
easy vision problem so this is the
design of a new ship that's going to be
around very soon it basically has a very
sophisticated hotel in it and well you
need to actually arrive at it by by
plane but yet it is a ship so these are
easy vision problems okay I hope you
agree with me that these are all easy
vision problems so for these easy vision
problems that our classification right
you can do two things a very traditional
approach that would be popular in 60s
and 70s is knowledge driven approach so
something like this so this would be
rule based model based grammar based so
you would represent parts of the object
as object parts and basically you create
a model a complicated model to try to
represent the model the object and try
to figure out what the model what did
what the ob's is whether it's a ship
where it's a car or whatever so this was
popular in the beginnings of computer
vision
so you would typically have complicated
descriptions of objects and no data
leveraging or almost no data leveraging
whatsoever so if you look at what how
things have been happening more recently
things have been basically being changed
from a knowledge-driven approach to a
data-driven approach be sure to do
classification these days so for example
one option is to use things like support
vector machine technology and that
basically has driven most of activities
in in classification computer vision
recently in 90s and recent years so
essentially the idea here is that
instead of going for those complicated
models you go for very simple models but
yet you leverage data he heavily so the
question I have for you is what would
you do I mean would you would you go
back to this age here and do complex
models and don't know that are
leveraging or would you you know just
continue what people are doing at the
moment with simple models and huge that
leveraging so what would you do that's a
question I mean you just continue doing
these I mean ah what's your body I the
first one is too boring okay so
basically this is what almost everyone
is doing it right okay so let's focus on
the second approach here so there you go
I mean one option if you want to do
simple classification have again just
remind you we are working here on simple
visual problems ok you want to do simple
classification one option is you just
use support vector machines extremely a
well-known very successful
classification technique okay and there
you go well you you don't need to do
support vector machines i mean there are
many ways to do classification one way
for examples to do logistic regression
instead of doing instead of learning the
boundary you just learn these
discriminative functions independent
separately and then you decide according
to to to the intersection okay
that is something well for example
logistic regression also discriminative
approach but still based on density
estimation techniques and there are many
other things you could do okay why am i
calling these problems easy vision
problems it seems and being arrogant
here but not there easy even problems in
this following sense because the output
is very low dimensional it's the number
of classes for example I want to
classify an object well I may have two
classes 10 plusses 50 classes even 100
classes but I would call this extremely
low dimensional okay well we usually
think these problems are difficult not
because the output is low dimensional
because the input is high dimensional
because images are very complicated
objects that's why computer vision is
difficult but my point in this talk one
of my points in this talk is that of
course this makes life difficult that's
true but this here makes life not as
difficult as it could be if the output
were also high dimensional then we would
have the really hard vision problems
okay some variant recognition today
people are starting to talk about lately
pixels actually doing segmentation
together with recognition which yeah
that's that's the point of this talk but
the recent versions of that I'm just
trying to draw the basically the
mainstream up to recent years and then
try to survey the recent years and do
what what has been done in the last
couple of years okay but that's a fair
point that's the point of this talk okay
okay so inference here is trivia what i
mean by inference you want to predict
the class membership of a given image
okay so basically inference is trivia in
the sense that well for a support vector
machine you just check which class has
highest margin score you can enumerate
the classes because you have a very
small number of classes easily and
logistic regression you just check which
class has higher probability under your
individual regression functions
okay so now let's talk about high
division problems which is what Rick
mentioned the people with me so this is
a hard fusion problem the estimation you
here have okay so cool image well no
stereo pair here have the ground truth
for this okay what i'm calling it is a
hard fusion problem because the input is
high dimensional but the output is also
high dimensional the output is another
image the output is not is not a simple
class label it's extremely high
dimensional likewise here so the input
is an image the output is yet another
image image denoising so could you get
from here to there efficiently and with
high accuracy so that's a hard vision
problem not a visual problem image
segmentation so there you go input is an
image output is very high dimension as
well another image okay this is bad
because this is my favorite team which
is matching and the image is not showing
up okay no problem I'll show later an
example of matching this graph matching
case basically what was up there is
basically a pair of images and matches
between features of those images the
input is a pair of images and the output
is also something very complicated which
is a permutation of the nodes of
specific points dimensional analysis
after everything right because having
two images together is basically
high-dimensional input
but that is an easy problem right can
you answer 10 images yeah and taking
their average right that's a high high
dimensional input high dimensional
output so just classify things by
dimension doesn't really tell you what
the harnesses problem oh I'll trim
getting your point I'd say you're saying
why what it makes a hard problem a hard
problem has a high dimensional input and
a high-dimensional output right the
problem of taking two images in
computing their average satisfies your
definition of with a hard problem no I
don't take these two strictly okay don't
take this too strictly this is more
pictorial kind of description of what
I'm talking about okay so essentially
you can also in principle think of due
to genetic approaches like we've
mentioned previously acknowledged driven
approach or a data-driven approach for
these class of problems okay you can
qualify this as differently i'm just
using easy and hard just to make you
remember when one month from now that's
you you've heard easy and hard because
if i had user other qualifies you
wouldn't remember so the question is
what would you do so my point here is
that for these hard vision problems
people steal a play in this game here
mostly okay most approaches are
knowledge-based so for example energy
functions are typically handcraft
examples mrs forced air mrf for
segmentation graph matching and a bunch
of all the discrete optimization
problems where your output is
complicated you have a very
sophisticated predictor instead of just
a sport vector machine that you are
basically instantiate each one of those
class and checking which has highest
margin score you have to run an entire
complicated algorithm in order to make a
prediction like here well you need to
solve an mrf here you need to focus
island here you know in other things so
you work really very hard at trying to
solve find the best solution for a model
that you don't know in the first place
which is that's the right model or not
because you just ran handcrafted energy
functions okay
good the influence my positive so good
be impressed is not enough we need to
learn the energy functions themselves
that's what we should be doing so
basically if you were an advocate of the
data-driven approach it for easy
problems why shouldn't you be an
advocate of the data developer for
difficult problems as well so there is
an inconsistency there so that's what we
need to do so we need to find good
solutions to the right problem not to
the wrong problem and the questions are
so why should be working so hard to
improve inference incrementally which is
what a substantial proportion of the
vision community is doing in discrete
optimization when we know that the
global Optima are poor anyway I mean
it's so much effort doing this I mean to
me doesn't make much sense why bother so
much were being so optimal when the
criterion being optimized is simply a
reasonable guess of what a good
criterion would be so I think we should
be asking those questions so here's an
example this is a beautiful example from
from a paper in 2005 so here is the
original image to cover image here's the
ground truth and here's the global
optimum according to a simple a pairwise
mrf with handcrafted parameters so look
at look at the differences between these
and that so this is really this is the
global optimum of the energy function so
this is what people are really writing
put more and more and more and more
papers to achieve this result here and
then when you compare this result of
that result you see this really crap if
you be extremely picky this is crap look
at the camera there's on camera here you
can see any camera so I mean shouldn't
we be balancing a little bit more how
much we are working hard on finding the
right solution to a given problem or
finally the right problem the right
question to be asking the first place so
here are a bunch of other examples of
this very issue by me also ianova
advising in the ICCB 2005 we're here you
have a bunch of images here have you no
solution obtained you with belief
propagation here solution with graph
cuts and hit the global optimum they
actually managed to find a global
optimum for a specific mrf pairwise mrf
energy function and then if you look at
the global Optima they are really not in
some cases they are quite far from what
you know what a human labor would
provide so why are so many people
concentrating their efforts on
optimizing optimally designer G function
if at the end you are going to get
something that's not that good anyway so
here is something I want to you to think
about so in red you have the quality of
an algorithms so here's the level of
sophistication of an algorithm here's
our rhythm one here is our rhythm to
this is every point in this line is a
single paper in Nigeria cvpr so people
are walking this direction here okay so
algorithm sophistication so this red
line here you have the quality with
respect to a poor energy function of
course that's improving okay in this
blue line you have a quality with
respect to real perception that's stuck
that's that that stuck it has been stuck
for a long while here and yet people are
publishing papers and Dean pay for
publishing those papers okay so what's
the point well that's well exactly so
people are taking these energy functions
for granted right and of course you are
improving with respect to that energy
function but so what the tentative
function was handcraft in the first
place you being extremely religious here
come on we are scientists in the machine
learning field learning energy function
has a name it's called structured
estimation or structured learning okay
inferring a global optimum of a given
energy function is called simply
inference this has the same name in
computer vision okay so when people talk
about structure prediction they are
really talking about the whole business
of predicting high dimensional output
and doing learning in the process of
doing so as well not only handcrafting
those energy functions but doing
learning leveraging data in order to
find what would be the right problem to
be solved in the first place so what
would be popular estimators in the
beginning of the talk with
cuz it support vector machines and
logistic regression so likewise here
people are creating extensions of those
models of those estimators actually for
this structure case as well today we
have something called structural support
vector machines so which is a cousin of
the SVM okay structural svms so
basically these two reference here is
basically you need to look at which are
the papers that introduced it same tools
of how to do learning when the output is
very very high dimensional because we
are talking about really high
dimensional imagine an image you cannot
enumerate all possible images and yet
that's the number of classes you have so
how do you solve that the learning
problem becomes extremely difficult it's
much more challenging than doing
influence likewise you can do something
different you can you can ask what's the
analogous of logistic regression for
this structure case and that has a very
popular name is called conditional
random field that's only logistic
regression for a different feature
vector yes matching all stereo is now
tracked but how you can see that
structures where
Jack exam application gravity is correct
has cracked the cottage because you know
because well because you just train a
guess label data right so you can get
you can have for example what you have
these days you can have good either hand
segmentations of correct stereo okay our
mirrors to fit that model bad some time
for the Keynesian random field is deals
they find potential functions you amass
a steamer you define the features you
don't define the you define a model
class and then you search with element
in your model class maximizes the
evidence of the observations whereas in
traditional models you just select a
element of your model class you just
select hand you handcraft your
parameters so therefore if you have a
large model class that you would realize
the entire model class by changing your
parameters you don't explore that entire
model class you just fix a single model
and you believe that that's the best
thing you can do then you worked
extremely hard at optimizing it yes so
if you address this later my question
shop but what about learning parameters
in mrs like marshall happened has
learned parameters sure but what's being
absolutely but the point is that you
want to optimize those parameters to
minimize the final loss which is for
example the loss of stereo for example a
hamming loss between what you are
predicting let's say and a hand label
just the inner product between and
minimizing that loss can be can be
tricky when reason is because marshall
work with Gaston mrs it was practical
but he was doing you know you can do
image denoising where with synthetic
training data
he was optimizing the loss between the
final they learned mrf and the final
output oh the basic problem you see is
that if you want to really minimize the
loss that's interesting like for example
hemming loss that loss is discontinuous
so you have a piecewise constant
optimization problem there's no hope of
using any smooth optimization techniques
to solve that so what I'm going to show
that these these instead optimize
likelihood which is something that
people are more familiar with yeah
logistic regression I mean everyone
knows how it works you just create a
more sophisticated more than you have a
complicated partition function so but
that has a problem that because you have
the problem of computing the partition
function but this is an interesting
alternative because here you have no
partition function issues so you just
look at the boundary you just look at a
few examples and this will be much
faster than this in general and what's
the principle he is to upper bound the
upper bound that crazy objective
function that you have because you have
the ideal loss you want to minimize
would be a very crazy hemming laws which
is piecewise constant I mean there's no
really way to do that efficiently but if
you have a decent surrogate loss that
kind of preserves a structure of that
original loss and that surrogate loss is
amenable to efficient optimization
that's what this is all about and this
has actually been extremely successful
although you know the first paper that i
know of that uses these in computer
visuals only thousand five but now we
did this in 2007 and then now people
have suddenly realized yeah we really
need to do this stuff okay conditional
random fields people have been using for
a bit longer in computer vision so this
was first proposed in 2001 but has very
nice statistical property so this is a
consistent estimator this is not
consistent estimator for example but has
serious problems because of the
partition function you look at if create
an entire probability distribution on
the images and that's e when you want to
learn you want to do great in the sand
then you need to estimate the
participant it's it's really bad so this
seems to be a very practical alternative
the first one so both have advantages
these advantages okay I'll move forward
here so just one example graph graph
matching here so the graph matching
probe is really a hard problem right so
if you want to take into account
pairwise constraints for example you get
a quadratic assignment formulation and
that can be really hard so the point is
that traditionally people just handcraft
these objective functions for graph
matching right you just say look I mean
these unary similarities will look at
sift features these quadratic
similarities will look at relative
distances or whatever and then you just
fix parameters and then you work really
very hard to solve that computer
tutorial problem and you don't you
didn't know in the first place whether
your objective was good or not the point
is that you can actually learn those
energy functions so these work for
example we use structured svm to solve
those energy function then we find some
very nice things for example I mean you
can model graph matching with
complicated combinatorial settings like
quadratic assign or you can monograph
matching simple controller settings like
linear assignment only look at match
between a individual pixel instead of
having pairwise constraints and that's a
tractable model it turns out that if you
learn that simple model you obtaining
results which are as good as you would
have obtained with a complex model
without learning this is something we
figure out in this in these examples
here this is what you get if you model
graph matching for example as linear
assignment which is efficient to compute
it will perform similarly with quadratic
assignment without learning why because
you are finding the right weight of the
sift features for example in such a way
that your final result is what you want
it to be because you have training data
so you engineer so basically you
automatically tune the relevance of your
128 shift shift
features for example so that that joint
weight will when you solve this
combinatorial problem produce an image
that is what you wanted to produce
because you have the output either by
hand label or by laser scans of for
example the case of adapt estimation
okay so this is one example so okay so
here my matches are up so this is my
favorite subject graph matching this is
just to show that okay in green here you
have correctly matched points in red you
have wrongly magic points okay this is
exactly the same model class it's just
that here we have handcrafted the
matching score and here we have learned
the other way around sorry so here have
handcrafted and here we have learned at
the matches course okay so you see that
you know there are many mistakes that
you can avoid by just tuning what's the
right model in your model class of
course here how many classes you have
any factorial if you in this case here
have 30 points here 30 points here I
have as many classes as possible matches
because my prediction here is the match
I'm predicting a match so I'm
parameterizing the algorithm that's
producing the match so it's like I have
a support vector machines with 30
factorial classes how do I solve that
that's why it's not trivial and then you
need to look at the paper to see these
techniques that people are using but the
point is you can improve you can yes you
can improve so here another example that
we have in cvpr this year which is
shaped classification to classify shapes
okay so one thing that people do in
shape classification for example is to
use matching scores to use the results
of matching scores to do classification
because you know that sometimes you know
if you remember the paper by belong here
at Ali I in 2002 it for me that was
basically shaped context features I mean
probably many people are familiar with
that so what essentially they were doing
they are trying to classify objects
basically matching score
ours okay but they were handcrafting
their matching score so you handcraft a
matrix course you produce a match that's
completely a function of how good was
your matching scars then you
parameterize the the final matches and
then you learn after that stage so you
do this right you trust your matches
completely then you do learning after
you produce the match you parameterize
that and you do learning but come on I
mean you may be doing learning
completely crap features here because
you have done shape matching the first
place completely trusting your
uncalibrated linear silent noggin so
what we doing this paper here we do
everything in a single shot so we meet
we optimize the matching score itself so
that the classification loss is
minimized okay so here is an example of
no learning so you produce a matching
okay you can match this chem against
this dog but the algorithm has wrongly
classified the dog and the camo as
belonging to the same class okay and
here if you do learning so you can you
use the matching as a means to
classification but you parameterize the
matching itself then you can recover you
can say well these two guys are camel
they belong to same class yes we're
learning better feature descriptors or
distances in feature space stays like
that yes sir you know and you have
training databases correct and incorrect
matches right so how does this work
differ from just learning a better
matching score because this is
optimizing the matching loss this is not
this one this is optimizing this is
structure prediction in that case you
were tuning your matching scores so as
to minimize a very low dimensional
surrogate this is going directly to the
output space and saying look I want
these matching matrix this permutation
matrix my loss that I want to optimize
is a different is the hemming loss
between two permutation matrices that's
extremely high dimensional so you go you
go directly to the problem that you
really would like to solve instead of
creating a
get low dimensional version what would
which paper i'm talking about winter and
qua matthew brown that here they've done
a series okay okay where they have sift
like features or they're trying to learn
better descriptors okay and they have a
database of which features actually
match there's no several million matches
okay the patches that are known to be
true matches in other matches that are
going to be false okay so they have a
loss function which is right so correct
or incorrect matching robbery right so
the question I have is what's the
algorithm that predicts the what's the
predictor in that case make Superman
that's right
in this case you learn how to make
action seriously it's a joint if you
wrap a more complex algorithm around it
you know you can still adjust I have
access to what's correct natural and
have access to the final thing you wrap
your matcher into some other bigger
black box and you evaluate the effort of
the black box that's the difference
right I think the main thing is that I'm
not optimizing in the scores of in of
individual matches here I'm not doing
that I'm optimizing the joint match the
quality of the joint match because these
two points cannot match to the single
same point for example I have an inject
injection constraint that's essentially
a bijection between these there so they
are in factoria possible things that I
need to optimize i'm not saying well
this guy is very similar to this one so
let's have a single parameter
calibration that no it's is a mod is a
more complex prediction model okay you
need the ground troop you well you need
to provide that manually but that that's
that's that is can be an issue in many
cases but there are two ways to
circumvent one way is to do a
semi-supervised version of these
learnings this learning scheme in a
semi-supervised version you would
provide a few matches you don't provide
the others but you can still generalize
the setting to marginalize over the
hidden variables for the others that's
one option the only option is for
example if you're doing shape matching
if you have a very simplistic setting
where you have doing something like this
you can easily create a semi-automated
labeling algorithm so you just say well
this guy's going to match these deals
going to mesh to that umesh maybe three
or four of these points and then you run
a very simplistic algorithm that just
complete the match and you use that for
labeling okay need to move forward here
to make sure we get everything done
here's yet another example this is this
is another work we've done nips last
year all the types of matching problems
will have new isometric matching cases
so you can also improve on by doing this
predicting a learning for near rigid
obviously just you just change the types
of features you have and type of
inference you use Junction trees and
circulate SVM's as well this is another
thing well we just submitted this but I
discovered today that it wasn't accepted
that at I ccv anyway so this is trying
to do something interesting recently
belanja grouping in san diego de they've
they've used conditional in the fields
to do joint object categorization what's
a joint object object categorization
imagine just for the sake of simplicity
that you could segment this image
properly okay so you could segment this
into a you know you have here for these
joint regions but you don't know the
labels of those regions you don't know
what they are but assume you could
segment them properly as a matter of
fact in order to assess the quality of
different algorithm you need to assume
that the segmentation algorithm is is is
independent of the model so let's just
assume you can segment this properly and
the question is which object is this
object here which objects these and
these and data okay so of course you
could think that you know I will create
a Reno classifier or create a vegetation
classifier a sky classifier ground
classifier run those classifiers and
predict things right but it's kind of
something simple because actually you
know that if you see a Reno you it's
likely to be above and not underground
whether it's likely to be under the sky
and not over the sky so different labels
of objects they don't occur
independently in images so if you want
to predict things you would like to
leverage a data set that what you've in
that particular data set you have
labeled ins and saying well this Reno's
are under this the sky over the ground
or if you if you see water and you have
something big over the water you know
this likely to be a ship not a car
something like that so you
to leverage these correlations right so
that when you want when you do
prediction you predict an entire
convenient Oriole structure in the
output you don't predict independently
these and data that guy but of course
that creates problems because you have a
combinatorial problem to solve right so
essentially have a more sophisticated
predictor but yet you can calibrate that
predictor using chain data so that's the
point so in this work we are
substantially improving on on the work
of the luncheon and collaborators so we
have to find out the venue to stick this
stuff in so here so this we just
submitted as well so what we are trying
to do in this case no image is here but
there is a plot assume you want to do
graph matching typically in graph
matching you make some assumptions like
for example I have I want isomorphism I
want harmoo morphism what I want is ami
trees there are all sorts of types of
assumptions that people like to do when
they do graph matching depending on the
type of the problem okay so what we do
here we completely we become completely
agnostic with respect to those
assumptions and we finalize everything
right and we have a unified model where
we just learned the weight of everything
so for example in this case here we have
shaped context features 60 of them here
we are learning the importance of that
and in this corner here we are learning
the importance of isomorphic features
isometric features or Mia morphic
pictures all the different types of
graph matching aspects that you can
think of so there is no point more in
talking about you know this is an
isomorphic graph matching problem is a
homeomorphic graph matching problem this
is just a graph matching problem you
parameterize everything you learn and
then here is your soft description of
your graph matching problem okay and of
course when you do that you
substantially improve on on on results
existing desertion and order okay so
conclusion for this first part and this
is the main the main master I want to
pass today the second part is a bit more
technical but
is the main master 12 path which is to
have simple prediction problems like
classification just we want to classify
objects people in general use simple
models like support vector machines
write and perform learning properly so
people know how to people computer
vision people have learned already how
to master these techniques here okay and
the results are improving improve
improve however when you have complex
prediction problems think of graph
matching think of image segmentation mrf
stereo and all that stuff okay people
use complex models but yes they are
starting to you is learning but it is
still not leveraging all the data that
you can leverage here so most people
actually still overlook learning in this
case and maybe we can still overlook
learning if you have a stable matching
problem where assume you have a
monochromatic image but imagine five or
ten years down the road when every image
you get even in your webcam will be
hyperspectral you will have 72 channels
how would you manually tune the stereo
parameters for 72 channels you better
start thinking ahead of time and
automatically learn all this stuff okay
so take home messages there exist
techniques that are low doing both
things complex models and learning
that's the first thing you should you
should take from this talk and the
second thing is that in this trade-off
between model complexity and data
leveraging if you think computer vision
is still far to the first side so we are
using very complicated models but we are
not leveraging as much data as we could
okay so I think a better balance is
possible here we should we should think
of ask these questions and give we
didn't have much easier yes I agree with
you that's true that's lightly that's
true my chest
last year that's right that's completely
legitimate argument but there are two
points here first that that's true but
that's not the whole story okay and
second even in the lack of completely
label data you can still use this stuff
so basically you can use a
semi-supervised version of this but of
course for that you need to work hard
because you need to look at the last two
years papers at nips understand all that
mats and different questions we've been
working on different questions I just
think that since I'm a mostly machine
learning person apply my stuff to vision
you know the way I see this is that look
let talk to the visual guide and say
look we have these tools okay and we can
really change things by using these
tools so let's let's try to talk people
in and try to excite people about using
these tools yes mytouch instead well you
are leveraging the Chilean desert
extreme the cabbage although such that
you can filter that the thing about the
missus is that the model will be twin
specifically traduction and data now you
may but worry for the answer is that
well improv he plucked in practice we
use you know you just do regularization
I mean in I'm not talk this is not a
technical talk right but in practice you
don't minimize only the loss on the
training set you minimize the loss plus
a regularizer that's basically
constrained the model class is saying
well are not going to learn an arbitrary
complex functions I'm going to learn
functions that are meet you know that
they do well on the training set but
they are also sufficiently simple you
just do regularization in practice
okay so this is the main message I had
for today so since I still have fifteen
minutes let me just tell you a few other
things that we are doing so this is
something excited about because we just
submitted this stuff it's very recent
and it has an application computer
vision convex relaxations of mixture
regression apply to motion segmentation
so here's a motion segmentation problem
so this is supposed to be just a single
a single image of an image sequence okay
so I have this car is moving the other
car layer is moving and you have the
background here and the fact is that you
want to segment these motions you want
to segment this motion so you want to
classify these the ground truth let's
put it this way of this segmentation you
know that this is one motion that's
another motion that's another motion the
motion model that we have like you want
to estimate from the mental matrix all
the stuff they're all linear regression
problems that okay so if we knew if we
knew to each of these three motions
every one of these features belongs we
could solve a simple linear model that
will estimate that motion simply just by
doing this squares regression okay the
problem is that we don't know the
problems that we don't know that this
guy here is and this guy here belong to
the same motion we don't have this
information in fact the membership the
motion membership for every one of these
points is a latent variable that can
attain three values in this case but you
don't know what it is okay so how do you
solve this problem if you observe the
membership you have a nice convex
problem that you can so close form these
squares but if you don't know how do you
solve it obviously these will also be a
very complicated optimization problem
because this will be a combinatorial
optimization problem you would ideally
have to so to look at all the post
Sybil configurations of three motions of
these points which is of exponentially
large set and solve the regression
problem for each one of those and find
at the end which configuration gave you
the best fit the best least square
solution of course you can't do that in
practice so what do you do so I'll tell
you what people do people so this is
setting ok so we have just in a more
visual way mathematical way here you
have mixture regression here's a bunch
of points he's another bunch of point
another bunch of points if you knew that
this belongs to the same line that this
belongs to the same line they belong the
same line you just saw three independent
regression problems but you don't know
that ok let's just assume for sake of
simplicity you know there are three
models ok you don't have a model
selection problem in other three models
in other straight lines but how do you
solve it so what's the typical answer
well the typical answer is well you have
a latent variable for each one of those
guys which is the membership of that
point so people just okay this would be
a good solution ok and people just use
the M that's what people do so what you
do you pretend you know for a solution
then you solve your problem you use that
solution to initialize and then solve
for the membership again then go back
and breeze tomato the model and then
solve again and brings tomato model well
we know very well that this function
that AEM is trying to optimize is a very
highly non convex function which is full
of peaks and valleys and moreover it's
discreet because we are optimizing over
the discrete space so it's piecewise
constant function is the post is the
worst possible to my station problem you
can have so easy i'm going to do well
well if you can afford for am running
over the silence now you can get in the
am you have everything a softer side at
the end you discretize ok so i can
believe this lots of local
all the original one thing is the
problem itself the other thing is the
model the problem is discrete the model
is soft softly exactly but still it's
really cooked well you can you I'm sure
many of you have played they have at
least may be implemented e.m once in
your lifetime or whatever and run em and
you can see the DM can really do very
badly it can you do very well but you
can we do very badly and the reason why
IM can do very badly that because it's
finding really poor local minima so how
do you go and solve this ok you can try
to do em or you can try to do something
else so here's something else we're
trying to do we're trying to instead of
we have a very complicated function here
you know very high-dimensional mutti
mutti model function and you want to
find the global optimum hear something
ok your global optimum and then yeah man
DME is gradient descent basically ok so
you if you initialize here you are going
to find this point if initializer you're
going to find this point but there are
millions billions of valleys here so
depending on initialization you're going
to do well depending you are not going
to do ok so what we do you construct a
convex upper bound on this function
instead of solving this problem we solve
this problem so we change the problem
yes is that bad well of course you're
not solving the original problem but the
question is if we happen to construct a
convex upper bound whose minimum of this
convex function is not too far from this
minimum here you've really gained
something because solving this is easy
and you obtain the same solution that
you would have waited if you could have
solve this prob ok so before telling you
the good news I'll tell you the bad news
the bad news is that there is no
existing algorithm I am aware of that
tells you these deviate the deviation
between this point and the optimal at
this point all what you can do at the
moment is construct a convex upper bound
which is sound in an intuitive sense but
you cannot really give them any
guarantees on how the solution is close
to this will be ok so that's the bad
news so the good news is coming so we
construct this convex upper bound on
this objective function here but
remember this here is this thing here is
very misleading because this problem is
extremely high dimensional but still
that's a convex function we know how to
optimize convex well there is nice
technology to do that in particular it
is not a simple this is not a simple
gradient the same kind of unconstrained
optimization problem this is a semi
definite program and among many possible
convex optimization problems is the one
of the words you can have ok this is not
going to scale basically you can solve
this for 300 observations 400
observation you cannot you cannot solve
this for thousands of observations so
this is not good typical interior point
methods so Barry type metals that solve
this problem so you info essentially
before stick on straights in the
objective function by a logarithmic
berry opening all the streaks ok and
then this is extremely expensive because
Kubek on the matrix of up on on the
square matrix oh it's it's you start at
six it's is going to be really bad so
that's what we do we reformulate the
original problem as a semi definite
program okay which is really bad to
solve but we figure out two ways of
solving this problem exactly without
doing a semi definite programming ok so
we bypassed completely the need for
using semi definite programming and this
is only possible because of the very
structure of the of this problem it
couldn't be possible in general so here
is I want I only have five mins I won't
go much in the table I want to give you
the intuition of what's happening so
every one of those observations I
mentioned previously let's call it X I
you have a latent variable for them
which is said I which is telling you
well to each motion that particular
observation belongs ok so now you
construct this VI variable which is just
a tensor product of these two guys so
this is not known this is partially
known this is known but is not know so
this vector here is this distance or
product of this thing that you know with
this thing that you don't know is
something that you know partially only
you don't know it completely and now you
can easily if you have this notation can
easily write the mixture regression
problem which are mixture of regression
problem simply as a regression problem
so here is your prediction here is your
observation he is a model so you have
just an inner product of your vector
with a parameter vector with with with
with v and you have a we assume in this
case least square so basically we have
you assume a Gaussian noise in your data
so here is the noise model okay
classical regression just that the key
difference is that here we don't have X
i we have see I which is something that
you don't know completely whereas in
traditional regression you would only
have X I because you don't have this
class membership ishii okay well it
turns out that you can reform like all
the stuff in a nice matrix form here
have a quadratic objective here you have
a linear objective because all that's a
nice Gaussian exponential family
everything becomes quadratic or linear
and here have a regularizer which
addresses the issue you've mentioned
previously so we want to penalize models
that are complicated essentially so we
have a Gaussian prior on the parameters
okay and what you want to do you want to
actually well there is some notation
problem is yeah this this is this
variable see here we want to solve yes
we want to solve a regret a traditional
least squares problem on w okay for a
fix it for a fixie but please not fix it
so we need to jointly optimize on this
we need to jointly solve this linear
regression problem in this combinatorial
problem okay so this is the original
objective that's as I mentioned before
very difficult you cannot discrete and
all this stuff so after lots of math you
can prove that this is a nice convex
relaxation for that problem and I won't
give you the tails but essentially what
you do you compute the dual of the
original problem use eventual reality
and you do a few math tricks and you
obtain this optimization problem here
and this problem is a convex problem
okay essentially you are optimizing
oversee this function here is concave on
CC because it's square negative here
it's concave in C and then you have a
semi definite constraint here because
this matrix m needs to be positive
semi-definite needs to have bound ligand
values and all that blah blah blah the
point is that you have a semi definite
program program but it's hard to compute
to solve this is an exact reformulation
of that problem so if you saw this
problem here if you solve this problem
here you will recover the same solution
then if you solve this problem here but
solving this problem is very expensive
and so in this problem is very easy
because this part here can be surveilled
by basically eigenvector computations
it's cubic you can solve this part
efficiently and this optimization
oversee can be done by grating the same
so essentially what you do
you alternate I convector computation
with gradient descent and easing
practice does really fast this version
of our reformulation runs as fast as GM
basically and then here is the algorithm
blah blah blah you need the input which
are the those parameters of your noise
model you need to solve I convector
computations you use bfgs just non
smooth convex optimization traditional
you know standard optimized a convex
optimization tools but this is much more
efficient than doing a semi definite
programming and using zero point methods
is much faster so this is scalable you
can solve this for thousands of points
ok this is the first reformulation you
can find another convex reformulation of
the original semi-definite program and
this is the ugly-looking of that thing
but you can prove that this is also a
convex optimization problem you have
also a semi definite constraint here but
that this same doesn't problem can be
solved efficiently as well it is not as
fast as the as the other one it's about
three times slower than here ok so here
is the algorithm ok no don't go much in
details but here are some pictures just
let's close with some images so here you
have a few data sets from motion and
here's a first data set every this the
ground truth and if you run am you run
the first reformulation the second
convex reformulation you obtain this
isn't sort of an easy problem because
eam is finding the optimal solution
already these guys also end up finding
the optimal solution now you have a
slightly more difficult problem here and
then you can start to start to see the
differences you observe the TM does a
few mistakes he and other mistakes here
and this convex reformulation seems to
be at least as good a GM is doing quite
well and this one here technically
should find the same solution because
these two guys here I saw me the same
problem ok these differences here are
doing to basically numerical differences
here's the ground truth here am does a
pretty badly here has all these mistakes
here over there and here we discover
this relaxes you you're still a far from
the original ground truth but at least
you make much less mistakes here and you
can quantify you have tables throwing
details you know oh we run am a hundred
times initialized randomly so that's the
setting okay we could run the M is the
best out of 100 iterate yeah went only
11 it's a complex problem if you solve
it 100 times you get the same solution
ok so the mid next time actually said it
was three years since you got the max
min yeah this is about the same speed
single iteration of the reasons no as a
about a hundred iterations of you yes so
being fair here of course you could run
him for ten thousand iteration but
that's going to really be be slow right
she got that many twice the number of
iterations here you start with you can
not make a lot of different possible
22 the 30th
oh well in theory yes in practice you
see that you can get difference if you
use ten iterations or are we found
difference between 110 iterations okay
but I don't we didn't really run
experiments with 1000 iterations to know
the answer is that Miss Lizzie
well it will find the same solution well
well well you can you mean us
dissolution to initialize um well we
haven't done that but you don't really
want to do that because that will be
really expensive because you have to run
twice the problem is yes but but you
know use this this is something that
people do you know initialize this
because you could have hit this point
may be right maybe your maybe you were
here it's a very valid question I mean
we haven't done the next you could have
hit this point here okay so you are you
are minimizing this function right but
you are not minimizing the function that
you really would care about that's one
thing you can do haven't done that but
yes definitely you can use this
conversation is initialize yes to the
energy of your auto commune of these
solutions original
that's true but there is a slight tweak
to that which is the following there are
hyper parameters in our model okay you
have dissolved and this gamma here you
can either choose to cross validate
those plans if you want to cross
validate or do some parameter search at
the end the best e m result and the best
convex relaxation result may be for it
slightly different models and then your
score may be different okay but we are
still in the initial experiments with
this one thing we want to do is well
just let's stick the same hyper
parameters and do a very you know 40
analysis and few body Sigma is the noise
Sigma is the noise okay so uh gamma
there's 11 calves it here we need an
extra parameter then then M we need this
gamma what this gum is telling you is
the claw clasp balance the balance
between the sizes of the classes okay
you can do this sort of fun this is
gamma is an upper bound on the size of
the largest class so if you want you
want no class to be larger than you know
fifty percent of the points you need to
have that gun so we we don't really have
a solution for avoiding that okay but
these alpha and these so this Sigma is
totally a property of your data right
but often not office is a parameter of
the model okay so you may end up with
slightly different guys if you cross
validator if not then your point is
valid okay so so overall and we have
many of other motions i'm just showing 3
here but in in our submission we have a
pain disease and all the stuff with many
other thing in it especially the max min
because the max mean is quite fast and
it seems to preserve quite a lot of the
structure of the problem right
okay so yes here symbolic signals just
the camera and that's why you have all
these things this green here the car in
that car this little one twice see
that's really I'm there any smaller
delicious there right what about what
about this family ball so just as I know
there are more you have two especially
if you notice i don't know I have to I
have to check this I don't exactly know
how many how many points here yeah oh
that's a big question we don't so these
are two fundamentally different
questions this is a model selection
question okay so there's no way you can
use a likelihood criterion to optimize
that because likelihood is monotonic on
model complexity of Korea so if you
create you should make more complex more
complex models you're always going to
obtain a better like okay that's a
fundamental question that's a
philosophical question that's the
problem of induction in science so it's
an open problem and you can use you know
several different model selections mdl
or whatever or you can try to be Beijing
and do all these hierarchical Bayesian
stuff because you for a completely
Beijing then you have no model selection
problem you just put the pile and keep
running and you know so can you speak up
oh yeah AIC be I see our model selection
criteria that's exactly what I'm saying
the models they Advent you're right you
are completely right the advantage of
the M is that since we have a
probabilistic model you can be as
Beijing as you want okay so you know you
can do what you say in this setting it's
not obvious how to do that I don't know
the answer
any other questions yep girl like more
than 10 years ago Blake worked on
something called graduated convexity
garden assignment no or grab a drink
wine on FX he was a continuation method
motivation is lateish a cobbler in the
vision community in the mid to late 80s
all lighting system and rinse off was
for cocaine but they were for
regularization problems with with
non-quadratic and her toys so they would
end Lancome books as well look far oh
yeah context so you would introduce a
graduated nonconvex ok ok so its
continuation about this weather really
I don't know if it's related or not
we might be because there's this idea at
least philosophical level right I'm sort
of having an approximating function at a
scooter yes
Oh
you've compared this with the am right
on
I think many that's not as the
state-of-the-art melon here
for this particular problem there
what would be the state that they are
well you look at the recent papers and
rented our yes yes yes thank you I know
I know and well there yes it would make
an attorney from yes now but which are
imposing an fi model on this and right
the Wi-Fi model and then the whole thing
becomes linear this is like a but what
really calls a generalized pca yes yes
right and then he also have some more
recent times I think it's seeming PR
2009 that's obviously what's good seeing
okay maybe I'll talk to him let's hear
dark which they're using some sort of
compressed sensing technique okay in a
way to solve GBC a problem so that when
looking at the results in Allison's
paper there
amazing makes me feel ashamed actually
here i published Bridget's maybe this
just kills you never know it there are I
need to look at that because remember
this is our our hammer that will look it
for a nail right we are not solving the
demotion segmentation problem we are
solving the mixture regression problem
and you're modeling motion segmentation
as mixture regression where you have
quadratic a quadratic right here okay
probably these models they are different
models they are not same model proposed
here the first the very first slides I
put up okay so this is a quadratic
basically regression problem so there
are different models so i would i would
have to reformulate new convex
relaxations for every different
objective yeah i'm actually technically
done so if you well okay no serious here
today and we have next time to have been
away arrange modified talks about be
nice if it
they will sound
so let me know maybe I'll confess
okay thanks we shirt thanks Rick yes
thanks everyone